why are you getting out of the car sir  I got [ __ ] back off back up mother  put your hands behind your back  oh she said that with authority I think  your gloves off Michael Jackson oh my  God  it happened so quickly he was gardening  so now oh oh  patriarchy has to run in yep there he  goes again the patriarchy doing things  for a woman when they don't even ask you  don't do that to a woman she goes you  don't ever do that to them when they're  restraining the guy like what what  happened  what happened to just being yeah men and  women are the same I am not saying that  a woman can't work on dispatch I'm not  saying that a woman can't be a pilot I'm  not saying a woman can't be a sniper I'm  saying that a woman can't do that he's  white you could have shot him